bonjour Claude Raynal merci beaucoup de
nous accompagner pendant cette première
demi-heure sénateur socialiste de la
Haute-Garonne président de la commission
des finances du Sénat on va longuement
évidemment parler du budget dans
quelques instants mais d'abord un mot
sur Emmanuel Macron qui fait le lien
entre la réforme des retraites et la
relance de l'économie est-ce que c'est
un lien qui vous paraît pertinent non
très sincèrement non alors
on sait que la volonté du président
Macron c'est de remettre les considères
que les Français travaillent pas assez
bon et donc il fait un lien entre le
travail le fait de reporter la retraite
et donc de faire des gens au travail et
la relance de l'économie mais ce lien il
faudrait pouvoir prouver d'abord que les
entreprises sont en capacité de garder
les hommes et les femmes de les
entreprises jusqu'à des âges avancés ce
qui n'est pas le cas voilà l'emploi du
Seigneur on en est très loin en France
aujourd'hui et donc ce lien me paraît
bon une tentative d'explication si je
puis dire voilà mais pas tout à fait
crédible vraiment sur le contexte
économique avant de parler du budget le
pic inflationniste n'est pas encore
passé la hausse des prix durant encore
plusieurs mois c'est ce que dit Bruno Le
Maire le ministre de l'économiste et
tire sur France Inter est-ce que les
Français sont quand même relativement
protégés avec les mesures du
gouvernement alors ils le sont plus que
dans des pays où il n'y a pas eu de
mesure particulière pour protéger c'est
le cas par exemple de l'Angleterre du
Royaume-Uni de manière générale sur
lequel il n'y a pas eu effectivement de
mesure de protection donc les mesures
qu'on peut être prises sur les boucliers
tarifaires etc ont bien entendu amener
l'inflation à un niveau plus bas que
dans d'autres pays et même parmi les
plus bas européens donc oui il y a une
action heureusement si vous êtes inquiet
pour l'économie de ces prochains mois
bah oui parce que pour différentes
raisons d'abord sur l'électricité plus
que sur l'inflation pour dire les choses
et puis également parce qu'on ne peut
pas de manière continuelle financer une
lutte contre le faisceau comme cela a
été mené pendant on va continuer à
parler de cette hausse des prix de
l'énergie puisque ça fait évidemment
partie du budget que les sénateurs vont
donc voter cet après-midi après près de
trois semaines de débats qu'elle est
bien de l'examen de ce texte qu'elle
modification il y avait vous apporter on
voit ça avec Alex pousse à
[Musique]
bonjour Oriane bonjour Claude rénal
bonjour et Alex c'est donc l'heure du
bilan ce budget 2023 doit d'abord faire
face à la hausse des prix de l'énergie
oui c'est l'urgence du moment avec ce
budget 2023 le gouvernement mobilise des
dizaines de milliards d'euros d'aide
pour faire baisser la facture
énergétique des aides qui ont été votées
par le Sénat le bouclier tarifaire pour
les particuliers l'amortisseur
électricité pour les PME le filet de
sécurité pour les collectivités en
revanche l'idée d'une taxe nationale sur
les super profits générés par cette
hausse des prix de l'énergie n'a pas été
retenue au final par le Sénat et
pourtant la gauche et les centristes
avaient proposé cette taxe sur les super
profits écoutez le président du groupe
centriste Hervé Marseille premier il est
politique problème il est politique
est-ce que on considère qui a des
profits exceptionnels à un moment donné
oui puisque on les taxe même au niveau
européen
donc qui soit nationaux ou européen
c'est qu'on les reconnaît mais on
préfère se planquer derrière les
Allemands derrière les autres qui eux
qui eux dès le mois de juillet ont
organisé des contributions nationales
les Espagnols les Italiens de Monsieur
Draghi Boris Johnson en Angleterre à ma
connaissance c'est pas des marxistes les
ministres alors au final pas de taxes
sur les sur-pères profits générés par
cette hausse des prix de l'énergie en
revanche cette alliance originale entre
les sénateurs centrist et les sénateurs
de gauche a permis de rejeter la
principale réforme de compétitivité
économique d'Emmanuel Macron sur ce
second quinquennat à la suppression de
la CVE la CVE qu'est-ce que c'est c'est
un impôt sur les entreprises qui est
perçue par les collectivités qui leur a
rapporté l'an dernier 8 milliards
d'euros le gouvernement veut supprimer
cette impôt pour renforcer la
compétitivité la droite du Sénat n'était
pas contre elle demandait juste un délai
d'un an en revanche pour les sénateurs
de du centre et les centres de gauche
hors de question de toucher à cette
impôt perçu par les collectivités
écoutez le patron des sénateurs
socialistes Patrick canard il n'est pas
question pour nous monsieur le ministre
en tant que groupe socialiste écologiste
républicain que nous acceptions que
l'impôt payé par des entreprises soit
transférées finalement à tous les
Français qui devront contribuer au
travers de la TVA au financement des
collectivités
territoriales donc c'est une situation
qui est totalement injuste puisqu'on le
rappelle le gouvernement avait prévu de
remplacer cette impôt des collectivités
par une part de TVA pour compenser cette
perte fiscale mais bon pour l'instant le
Sénat a rejeté cette réforme et puis
toujours concernant les collectivités
locales et bien hier soir une grande
majorité de sénateurs ce sont opposés à
ce que le gouvernement appelle le
contrat de confiance entre l'État et les
collectivités alors le principe est
simple les collectivités territoriales
doivent respecter l'objectif de diminuer
leurs dépenses de fonctionnement de 0,5%
en volume et si ce n'est pas le cas
l'État pourrait envisager des sanctions
prière dans le débat le ministre des
comptes publics Gabriel Attal a voulu et
bien cité sur cette notion de confiance
au cas où on constaterait que pour une
catégorie de collectivités locales il y
a un décalage très fort par rapport à
l'objectif qu'on s'est fixé à ce
moment-là on ouvre le capot entre
guillemets et on regarde s'il y a une ou
plusieurs collectivités qui ont tiré
leur catégorie ou leur strates vers une
dépense importante et on essaye de
savoir pourquoi il y a une discussion
avec elle et si on se rend compte que il
y a pas de raison objective locale qui
justifierait on s'accorde avec elle sur
une forme de retour à la trajectoire
c'est ça les contrats de confiance voilà
bah c'est contrat de confiance une
grande majorité de sénateurs n'en veut
pas car ils estiment que cela va mettre
les collectivités sous la tutelle
budgétaire de l'État Claude rénale a
d'abord sur la hausse du prix de
l'énergie c'est vraiment l'urgence de ce
budget 2023 est-ce que c'est le bon
budget pour faire face à ce phénomène
c'est difficile à dire difficile à dire
parce que les choses sont très
imprécises en réalité la question c'est
comment les prix de l'énergie vont
bouger dans les prochains mois personne
ne le sait réellement et puis d'autre
part il y a une proposition qui est sur
la table mais cette proposition sur la
table elle est pas faite finalement le
comprendre par rapport à un besoin elle
est faite par rapport à une capacité à
faire autrement dit l'État a des
capacités budgétaires qui sont
maintenant limitées et en fonction de
ses capacités budgétaires il prévoit un
système donc est-ce que ce système sera
de nature
par exemple pour les entreprises à
sauver les entreprises qui ont vraiment
d'énormes difficultés aujourd'hui sur le
plan électrique on connaît les
professions qui sont largement touchés
mais également donc les grands
entreprises qui utilisent l'électricité
de manière électro-intensive donc de
manière très forte donc comment tout ça
va se finir aujourd'hui sincèrement le
risque il est là il est pas tellement
sur l'outil il est de savoir si ce qui
n'est possible de mettre en place compte
tenu des capacités financières de la
France aujourd'hui et suffisant ou pas
il y a quelques doutes est-ce que ce
sont les bonnes mesures Alex a appelé
les mesures qui figurent dans ce budget
est-ce que ce sont les bonnes ou est-ce
que vous dites il faut aller vers un
quoi qu'il en coûte énergétique contenu
de la situation pour les ménages les
entreprises et les collectivités
il faut on ne peut pas tout faire c'est
une certitude donc il faut faire des
choix il y a un problème industriel qui
est grave parce que les entreprises une
fois qu'elles ont fermées rouvrent pas
voilà elle se déplace c'est-à-dire elles
peuvent aller dans des pays Bruno Le
Maire a juste titre l’évoque pas valait
très très vite faire des investissements
dans d'autres pays où le coût
énergétique est moins grand donc ça
c'est un sujet tout à fait tout à fait
important donc est-ce qu'on répond à
tout pour les collectivités locales
réponse non plus et non plus et il y
aura bien entendu des trous dans la
raquette mais ça on le sait dès qu'on
prend des mesures de cette nature cela
fonctionne pour une partie du spectre et
certaines collectivités ne pourront pas
suivre et donc il y aura sans doute des
aides ponctuelles qui vont être alloués
à des collectivités qui en fin d'année
ne boucleront pas leur budget ou en fin
2023 également et justement sur les
collectivité le Sénat a voté et bien le
rejet de la suppression de la CVAE cette
impôt sur les entreprises perçues par
les collectivités territoriales ça c'est
une victoire du Sénat dans ce budget en
tout cas c'est une à ce stade c'est une
communication qui est forte d'ailleurs
sur la c.v.e je voudrais indiquer deux
choses c'est que c'est le Parlement tout
entier qui ne l'a pas voté puisque je
vous rappelle simplement que c'était
avant le vote sur cette question à
l'Assemblée nationale il y a eu le 49-3
donc l'Assemblée nationale n'a pas voté
la suppression de la ciae le Sénat n'a
pas voté la suppression de la CVAE et si
le gouvernement décidait comme il
l'annonce de le remettre avec le 49-3 à
l'Assemblée nationale ce serait un déni
de ce qu'est la vision du Parlement et
le travail du Parlement je rappelle que
l'impôt c'est la première responsabilité
level impôt décidait de l'impôt c'est la
première responsabilité du Parlement et
puis il y a une autre mesure à laquelle
tout le Parlement s'oppose c'est ce
fameux contrat de confiance entre l'État
et les collectivités pour diminuer un
petit peu les dépenses de fonctionnement
des collectivités locales là aussi vous
craignez que le gouvernement passe en
force sur cette mesure avec le 49-3
écoutez il y a eu quand même un travail
de fait par les parlementaires auprès du
gouvernement extrêmement fort
extrêmement solide il y a eu également
un travail des associations d'élus et la
première ministre quand elle est venue
au pas des expositions
elle a eu des propos plutôt rassurants
cette question on espère bien que cela
sautera mais il y a une raison qui est
quand même fondamentale là-dessus c'est
qu'aujourd'hui on peut pas demander aux
collectivités dans un moment justement
où il y a une inflation très forte où il
y a une surenchère sur les coûts
énergétiques sur les coûts de
l'alimentation etc de devoir en même
temps être sur une vision de réduction
de la dépense enfin il y a quelque chose
qui ne va pas qui ne correspond pas
quand tout est calme on peut discuter de
tout mais quand tout est agité c'est pas
le moment d'en refaire d'en rajouter et
elle explique ce qu'on fait le bilan du
budget le budget c'est aussi un examen
ministère par ministère le Sénat
vraiment examiner ces budgets qu'est ce
qu'on peut en retenir il y a des budgets
qui ont été totalement approuvés par la
majorité de droites du Sénat les budgets
de la police et de la justice ont forte
hausse l'année prochaine tout comme le
budget de l'éducation qui prévoit de
revaloriser le salaire des enseignants
en revanche une majorité de sénateurs
ont rejeté le budget des dieux au
logement et les crédits prévus pour
l'asile et l'immigration car les
sénateurs dénoncent la politique du
gouvernement dans ces deux domaines et
puis le Sénat peut voter des budgets
tout en les modifiant en profondeur et
en rabotant certaines dépenses c'est ce
qui a fait par exemple la droite
sénatoriale pour l'aide médicale d'État
qui est versée aux étrangers en
situation irrégulière moins 350 millions
d'euros et un panier de soins réduit une
enveloppe également réduite de 500
millions d'euros pour la prime à la
conversion vers un véhicule électrique
car les sénateurs estiment que sa
finance surtout l'industrie automobile
chinoise également une réduction de 800
millions d'euros de la politique de
l'emploi et 200 millions d'euros en
moins pour l'aide au développement ça ça
a été voté hier soir Claude rénale ce
que dit la droite c'est que à un moment
il faut quand même réduire un petit peu
les dépenses publiques contenues de
l'état de notre de notre dette et de
notre déficit
c'est très c'est très bizarre ce que dit
la droite parce que d'un côté elle vote
la c.v.e elle le reporte dedans mais
elle le vote c'est à dire quand même une
perte pour les ressources de l'État de 8
milliards en deux ans juste ça juste ça
et après on vient chercher à grignoter
200 millions ici 100 millions ici 500
millions sans qu'il y ait d'ailleurs
vraiment de de préétude montrant
l'intérêt de le faire alors on a souvent
un discours de nature très politique on
l'a vu sur l'aide médicale que la me
pour les étrangers bon de manière
extrêmement claire c'est un discours
politique bon et puis de l'autre côté on
a une volonté de montrer que l'on
chercherait à maîtriser la dépense mais
la démonstration n'est pas vraiment fait
tout de même politiquement est-ce que
vous avez senti la majorité de droite et
du centre du Sénat un peu vaciller car
on l'a vu il y a eu des alliances
originales entre la gauche et les
centristes
voici je ne sais pas je ne crois pas
mais ce que je crois c'est que il y a eu
une volonté d'affirmation effectivement
des centristes en tout cas si c'est ce
que vous voulez me faire dire alors oui
je le confirme quelle lettre votre
position votre vote sur ce budget et le
vote du groupe socialiste
donc on a on a votre négatif ne fusse
qu'encore une fois parce que on a un
débat sur la dépense et ce gouvernement
refuse d'avoir un débat sur la recette
et non seulement il a pas de débat sur
la recette mais encore une fois il
prolonge finalement une technique de
baisse d'impôt qui a ensuite se retourne
quand on baise les impôts on a eu
beaucoup d'impôts sur les sociétés la
taxe d'habitation tout ça ça fait des
milliards et des milliards si vous
voulez et donc ça fait par an on en
était déjà rendu à 55 60 milliards et
quand on rajoute la c.ae parce que non
j'ai pas de doute que malgré que je ne
considère pas ça comme tout à fait
logique et tout à fait normal le
gouvernement va s'y tenir et donc on
continue à baisser la recette et puis
ensuite bien on se tourne vers les
Français à travers effectivement la TVA
et ses augmentations qui doivent
permettre de payer ou par la dette ou
ensuite par des mesures sociales qui
viendront comme la retraite comme ça a
été indiqué tout à l'heure et corriger
finalement des belles impossibles qui ne
passent pas tout à fait justifier encore
une fois baisser l'impôt quand on a un
pays en croissance pourquoi pas ça fait
partie de la palette des possibilités
pour augmenter un peu la dépense on peut
aussi réduire l'impôt mais quand la
croissance est nulle comme ça va être le
cas en 2023 comme ça a été le cas en
2019 ou 2020
pour les Français mais évidemment mais
évidemment par exemple dernier point on
a la dernière tranche vous savez de taxe
d'habitation pour les 20% qu'on est
revenu les plus élevés oh attendre deux
ans trois ans pour ces 22% qui reste un
peu pour cette dernière tranche je crois
que personne n'en mourait voilà mais je
crois qu'il serait plus important de
garder l'argent pour aider encore une
fois les familles les entreprises à
passer la crise énergétique que avoir
une baisse d'impôts aujourd'hui
Alexandre et moi sur la suite improbable
49-3 et oui au final le gouvernement
devrait passer en force ce budget à
l'Assemblée nationale avec le 49-3
est-ce que vous avez déjà quelques
garanties sur ce que le gouvernement
pourrait garder en termes d'apport du
Sénat dans cet examen du budget est-ce
que vous discutez déjà avec le
gouvernement les garanties si vous
voulez on les aura à dernière minute
c'est la règle de cette négociation de
ce type de négociation en sachant en
plus qu'il y a le projet de loi de
programmation des finances publiques qui
est toujours pas dans la CMP n'a pas eu
lieu et qui est mise en balance donc là
c'est un peu c'est la négociation entre
députés et sénateurs sur une version
commune exactement des deux textes
c'est-à-dire le PLF et la loi de
programmation qui vont être traités
et donc c'est de texte connaîtront
finalement une réponse très rapidement
entre le vote qui aura lieu et la CMP
aura lieu ce soir et là très rapidement
il y aura vous êtes optimiste sur cette
commission mixparitaire ce soir pensez
qu'il peut y avoir un accord député
sénateur absolument pas il peut pas y
avoir d'accord d'abord de fusques sur la
sur la trajectoire
la droite à une position très fermée sur
le sujet et donc de toute façon il n'y
aura pas effectivement une CMP
conclusive mais par contre il peut y
avoir gardé dans le texte un certain
nombre de sujet intéressant dans des
domaines dans des missions sur
lesquelles il y a eu des propositions de
fait il y a quand même beaucoup
d'amendements qui ont été votés on
espérer que quelques-uns restent dans le
texte final et on suivra ça
on parle à cyberattaque
et chez vous maintenant voir l'actualité
dans votre département va Toulouse on
tourne Eric berger bonjour Éric merci
d'être avec nous rédacteurs en chef
adjoint de la Dépêche du Midi
Eric vous faites le point sur les
coupures de courant non c'est par le
gouvernement comment s'y prépare-t-on
oui en effet on a consacré deux pages à
ce sujet à cette question et fameuse
question est-ce qu'il faut craindre des
coupures d'électricité cette hiver alors
on rappelle dans notre dossier les
propos plutôt rassurants du chef de
l'État ce week-end qui expliquait qu'il
ne fallait pas paniquer que si chacun
faisait des efforts on passerait cet
hiver sans sans difficulté toutefois on
rappelle également dans notre dossier
les propos du patron de RTE qui confirme
qu'il y a bien un scénario dans le pire
des cas en cas d'hiver rude et de
consommation élevée un scénario qui
verrait 20 à 28 coupures d'électricité
très ciblées sur des zones géographiques
bien bien définie des sûr de deux heures
environ ce produit cet hiver alors le
sujet fait déjà polémique au niveau
politique
on s'interroge dans ce dossier pour
savoir quelles seront les sites
prioritaires ceux qui pourraient être
concernés par ces fameux délestage il y
a environ 60% des Français qui
pourraient être touchés par les coupures
d'électricité alors le patron de RTE
souligne également il est encore appelé
hier que les français faisaient des
efforts que la consommation
d'électricité avait plutôt baissé
d'environ 6%, là où l'objectif c'est
d'atteindre les moins 10%, mais il y a
encore des efforts à faire et puis
évidemment on le rappelle dans ce
dossier tout ça éternel aussi en
relation avec l'état de notre parc
nucléaire puisque le patron d'EDF encore
rappelé que sur 56 réacteurs une
vingtaine aujourd'hui ne fonctionnait
pas mais que l'objectif était que au
début
2023 au pic de l'hiver en soi au maximum
de nos capacités sur ce parc nucléaire
enfin dernier point qu'on a souligné
dans le dossier c'est que parmi les
sites non prioritaires y a les écoles et
les ministères de l'éducation à
souligner que les écoles pourraient être
touchés par des coupures d'électricité
ce qui voudrait dire très concrètement
des fermetures de classe ce qui a
provoqué des IA des réactions de colère
des fédérations de de parents d'élèves
alors j'ai une question pour pour Claude
rénal que je que je salue est-ce que
vous estimez que le gouvernement en fait
assez pour se préparer les Français à
cet hiver et
éviter les coupures d'électricité
d'électricité puis vous-même est-ce que
vous craignez ces coupures de courant et
leurs conséquences
tout simplement moi je commence à
trouver qu'on passe tous les jours d'une
crainte à une autre et que d'une
certaine façon il faut séparer les
sujets il y a des sujets extrêmement
importants et des sujets qui le sont un
petit peu moins et il faut en tout cas
les traiter toujours avec la tête froide
donc je partage un peu l'idée que il
faut quand même regarder les choses avec
sinon sérénité du moins avec sérieux et
ne pas sans arrêt avoir l'impression
d'inquiéter les gens sur tous les sujets
et régulièrement franchement quand on
regarde quand on regarde l'actualité on
peut inquiéter en permanence surtout les
sujets on est très mauvais en justice on
est très mauvais dans les hôpitaux on
est très mauvais enfin on est très
mauvais partout quoi bon si on suit un
peu l'actualité la façon dont elle est
retransmis donc ce qui me paraît
important c'est ce qui est dit c'est à
dire que évidemment maîtrise pas ni les
températures
ni la façon dont les centrales vont
tourner exactement on peut imaginer des
choses mais il peut y avoir des risques
ce qui est important ce que je pense que
les Français peuvent très facilement
comprendre ce qui se passe peut-être pas
l'admettre dans un pays où on a toujours
expliqué qu'il n'y avait pas de problème
grâce au nucléaire bon donc on a bien
des problèmes et et et cela suscité des
questions mais je crois que ceux qui est
important c'est qu'il y ait des
réflexions qui soient faites pour
cranter les difficultés et trouver des
solutions de bon sens chaque fois que
c'est nécessaire question de l'école
chez un mot juste la on est sur un
problème là vous voyez on sort de la
politique on est sur un problème
d'ingénieur c'est-à-dire des réseaux
voilà donc on peut couper l'électricité
sur une zone et puis ensuite on fait
tourner les zones or la difficulté c'est
qu'il y a des écoles dans toutes les
zones c'est un peu ça c'est très réparti
alors que les hôpitaux c'est très clair
c'est très limité à Toulouse peut-être
trois quatre plus quelques cliniques
très bien mais quand on regarde les
écoles c'est tout de suite des dizaines
et des dizaines d'écoles et donc ça
couvre sa maille tout le territoire et
c'est compliqué d'éviter des ruptures je
pense
Eric sur un autre sujet important
évidemment notamment du côté du
Sud-Ouest la sécheresse
l'agence pour les agriculteurs
oui on consacre effectivement un article
aujourd'hui dans nos pages régionales
sur cette question les agriculteurs qui
se réunissaient hier sous l'égide de la
chambre régionale d'agriculture
d'Occitanie et qui en fait on fait le
constat effectivement d'une année
catastrophique en termes de sécheresse
et qui réclame la relance de projet de
barrage comme celui de Charles en
Haute-Garonne qui avait été abandonné
depuis 2007 alors la question pour pour
Claude rénal c'est est-ce que cette
question du réchauffement climatique de
la sécheresse et de l'impact sur
l'agriculture la réponse c'est de
multiplier les barrages les retenus
d'eau les retenues colinaires également
c'est ce que réclame les agriculteurs
quel est votre position sur cette cette
question d'abord voyez entre les deux
questions qu'on m'avaient posées il y en
a une finalement sur laquelle l'homme à
la maîtrise c'est la question de
l'électricité et il y en a une qui nous
dépasse totalement c'est le
réchauffement
nous dépasse en tout cas sur lequel les
réponses sont de long terme pour arriver
à résoudre donc ça c'est beaucoup plus
grave comme sujet effectivement alors
après on a toujours les deux débats
qu'on connaît bien entre la moindre
consommation d'eau par les agriculteurs
nécessaires et la création de la
colinéaire complémentaire et
supplémentaire c'est un point
d'équilibre et il faudrait arrêter de le
présenter si vous voulez toujours alors
chacun est dans son rôle évidemment les
agriculteurs sont dans le rôle en
demandant de l'eau pour l'agriculture
mais en même temps il faut qu'il soit
conscient et je crois qu'ils le sont qui
leur font aussi réduire leur
consommation d'eau merci merci merci
d'avoir été avec nous coupure électrique
la France sous tension c'est à la Une de
La Dépêche du Midi aujourd'hui merci
beaucoup
Eric berger d'avoir été avec nous depuis
Toulouse merci Claude Raynal d'être venu
dans 20 minutes dans le club des
territoires on parlera des cyberattaques
de retour dans l'actualité avec
notamment cette cyberatakos centre
hospitalier de Versailles on sera en
direct avec le maire et co-président du
conseil de surveillance de ce centre
hospitalier qui nous racontera
concrètement ce qui s'y passe mais
d'abord on va accueillir notre prochaine
invité c'est Philippe juin qui nous
rejoint